Full Speed Ahead dishes it out of the wing save
a s a h rebound score the Blue Jackets capitalize
on the rebound Jak be taking the rebound off the
Marko shot and we're tired at one well the Blue
Jackets fans are excited here fanelli picks up
an assist but it starts with marchenko deep in
his own end you can see Flyers are changing he
takes advantage sucks everyone to the middle of
the ice and then Jake Bean the defenseman all
the defenseman are on their toes here to start
this game for the blue J Jack fenti shot creates
the rebound and there's Bean on the spot and the
Blue Jackets are on the board and there are the
fenes yeah boy are they excited First National
Hockey League point Adam fan Tilly well we've
already seen Adam Fant Tilly record his first
NHL point in his first NHL game his mom and
dad are Hill Juliano and Julia how thrilling
a moment was that for you you've seen your son
do some big things that had to be a great moment
it's absolutely absolutely incredible and to
do it here at home in front of these amazing
fans is it's unbelievable I'm I'm overwhelmed
overwhelmed Julia all the car rides all the
early morning practices and now this where does
this rank in all of your son's achievements it's
just incredible you know what I said to
somebody today Columbus is home we feel
it we're so excited that Adam's able to spend
his 19th birthday here and we're able to be
part of this organization and this city we love
it what a great way to celebrate an Adam Fant
rims he knows your news he wants to make your
last year a good one as well ah good to hear